you're looking for a more convenient way
to charge your new 3dsxl intend OHS
official charging cradle might be the
perfect solution the narrow and
lightweight cradle allows you to drop in
and take out your new 3dsxl quickly and
easily when you set the 3d s in the
cradle two prongs rise up from the
bottom of the slot to meet the handhelds
two contact points on either side of the
EC adapter port the cradle ships on its
own so you have to provide your own AC
adapter and connect it to the port on
the underside of the unit depending on
how you want to orient the cradle you
can use one of two channels to
discreetly feed the cable into the unit
though Nintendo hasn't announced the
cradle for North America it's easy to
import one from Japan online for about
$20 from websites like eBay or play
Asian it's a good-looking and practical
accessory that will give you an easy and
convenient way to both charge and rest
your new 3dsxl
it's worth noting that while the cradle
might be tempting to current 3d s and
3ds XL owners the unit is only
compatible with new 3ds XL systems for
more gaming hardware and tech coverage
stay tuned to game tech at GameSpot calm
you